[Music]
yes this is a gold medal match of the
protest league
st louis archbishops versus armenian
eagles
oh speaks of story oh super gm's
fabiano dominguez wesley so
jeffrey strong can i compete
for the world championship or
will they be left with nothing but [ __ ]
and
dreams find out
now
the st louis archbishops the definitive
pro-chess league dynasty
with world championships in 2017 and
last year
and a bronze medal in 2018 the
archbishops led by fabiano caruana
have won their third championship in
four years
but it was controversial with the
armenia eagles disqualified
for a chess.com fair play violation
today we run it back and give saint
louis it's just due
it's time the championship
the saint louis archbishops versus the
armenia eagles
hello and welcome everybody to the st
louis archbishop special i'm your host
grandmaster
dennis borosch thanks again for
mike comer kind words to people
a bit of an encouragement you can't
really live without it
in any case if you might have not heard
the archbishops are crowned
champions after the armenian team
has been disqualified
and that leaves the archbishops
on the top winning the championship
winning back to back with this 2020
victory talking about
the victory we are going to look at
the best moments of these saints
archbishops
featuring dominguez wesley so
caruana and many many others
like huang liam was also part of it even
though did not play
in the field for the final match-ups
as was war ocobian so this is
a special synthesis archbishop
special so you are going to see
some rare footages with interviews
with lenny dominguez and var ocobian who
was also part of the team
although was mostly doing commentary
during the
semi-finals and finals and
these footages are from a charity golf
event
so if you see golf carts and golf clubs
don't be surprised it was for a good
reason
and a good cause anyways talking
about some chess games let's get into it
and this first game was played between
mamedyarov
dominguez in the quarterfinals
actually a very important match up
because mamjarov was the india yogi's
hot player going in to the match
so extinguishing him and getting
at least a half a point was very
important
so let's take a look what happened in
this game between
mamedyarov and dominguez d4
no big surprise here mahmud yarov has
always been more of a close player
he never really played e4
probably not a big bobby fischer fan
after all c4 e6 knight c3
d5 and this has been actually the height
of fashion because of
vladimir kramnik's efforts oftentimes
he would even dare take with his knight
instead of the pawn
and look for some counter play in these
type of positions
however muhammad yarov is happy to play
a close position with bishop g5
bishop e7 knight f3 h6
and normally you would see bishop h4
castles e3 this has been seen
in plenty of matches candidates matches
the world championship match
between kasparov and karpov and the
candidates match
between spelman and short
but here as you might have expected from
an important match
after h6 mahmud yarov came up with a
little
wrinkle he played at bishop f4 here
and this actually transposes to the
bishop f4 line
with black already committing with h6
whose does this favor most likely
nobody because that h6 pawn move
does gain a tempo that move is useful
you
control that square however it can be a
hook
to g4 g5 attacks
so here lenny castle
e3 and surprise surprise
g4 will be a big threat if you're not
careful
so if b6 this could run into g4 ideas
if you would dare capture there's rook
g1
and the move f5 that would normally work
doesn't really work here because of this
idea of bishop h6
and again that extra pawn move
of h786 was
not really a good inclusion
in this case so
instead of b6 dominguez went for the
critical c5 line
now c5 is the main move but without
h7 h6
dtx c5 happened bishop c5 queen c2
knight c6 queen a5 and talking about
armenian ingenuity and
creativity rook a2 is a nadanyan a short
idea
which actually is a very very
interesting
preparing ideas such as b4 now note
b4 wouldn't work here because of bishop
b4
and at the end of the day the a1 rook
would be hanging
however mamedyarov didn't go for that
and meant
for the brutal caveman-like chess
and castle long and it seems that
everything is fine
for black but the storm is a bruin
g4 g5 is likely to show up
very very soon however
dominguez is in a rush to get counter
play
now here bishop e7 was played b4
and guess what wesley faced g4
actually vastly was playing white versus
nakamura
and this attack is actually quite
dangerous
and in a long tussle actually wesley
won the game so dominguez
played knight e4 instead saying hey i
do want to put pressure on your king
before
you could cause any drama around
my side of the board
c takes d5 and i take c3 queen takes
queen takes bc takes king c2
e takes d5 rook d5 and for the initiated
you'd think well white is up a pawn what
is there really to worry about
the thing is this king on c2
does not feel that comfortable and this
rook is
very much likely to be in danger
in the future so bishop e6
dominguez immediately pounces and you
can again see
that this h6 extra move is very
beneficial there are known ig5 ideas
which can be very annoying when playing
with black
rook b5 b6 knight d4
all very logical knight takes d4
and interestingly enough here mama jarov
makes a decisive mistake
he decides to take with the c pawn when
in fact e takes d4 would provide
a very nice little shelter for his king
and probably would be slightly better
but for some inexplicable reasons
mamadarov wanted to go for something
very sharp and decided to take with this
spawn
and now watch how dominguez dismantles
this way of playing rook c8
king d2 rook c1 no longer does that move
in the corner can ever move yeah i'm
talking about that king
ain't feeling too shabby especially as
my rook
is about to join the party via rook fc8
and rook c2
d5 trying to close it off but
lenie is insistent he's going to play
bishop f5 and say hey
i'm joining your king on the second rank
rook b3 rook c2 check rook a2
over defending the bishop and preparing
the very elegant checkmate of rook c8
rook c1
note you can't really go bishop d3
because at the end of the day
you would lose your rook in the corner
rook c3 bishop b4
and that's one of the things that super
grandmasters do
if they have past pawns on the side
they're gonna
utilize them rook c4
a5 let's push him let's
push them all bishop e5 well
if you give us a pawn i'll take it d5
ship d4 b5 rook c7
bishop d6 check now
the main idea of bishop d6 is is to
undermine
this rook and bring it to a much worse
square
he could have checked on a3 first but
decided it's
better not to have a rook on the seventh
d1 bishop b2 once you're up upon
every exchange is to your benefit
take six look d8 king e2
a4 and now you can see the situation has
changed dramatically white used to have
lots of pawns in the center now there
aren't any pawns that rook is still
sad in the corner not to talk about this
bishop on f1
and this pawn is speeding away to
transform into lady
king f3 followed and another one
again that rook is stuck in the corner
g4 bishop d3 bishop g2
and at last that rook is about to escape
but it's too late and here mahmoud yarov
resigned as after bishop h1 a3
and this pawn is queening and that
actually shows
how clutch the scene was whenever
there was an important moment so this
one
actually made sure that the archbishops
are going to qualify versus the yogis
talking about dominguez we did have an
interview with him
at the golf cart watch
my last two tournaments before the
semi-finals and then the finals were
not especially good so i was
just trying to basically not to ruin
things like i knew
our team that's very strong i mean
especially wesley was playing extremely
well during the whole season
and fawzi as well so i knew that
our team was basically the favorite so i
was
just trying to play well i did well
against the chinese team and then
and in the finals i didn't do
so well but i think yeah in general it
was uh
um it was it was not bad
and but again i lost the the first game
which
it's always tough after that because you
you lose some confidence and then
it's kind of more difficult to play but
overall i was just sad because i felt
that we
deserved to win i mean we were playing
so well during the whole season
and i felt that we were the
strongest team and we deserved to win i
mean
then we found out that
there were some fair play violations and
of course it's always sad to hear
and sad that it happens but yeah as we
all know
online chess has that kind of problem
that
you have to take measures in in order to
try to avoid
that as much as possible but yeah it can
always happen
well i felt relieved because i first of
all i
felt that uh the
the the loss in the final round i was
uh uh to a large extent
guilty for it because i um i did half
out of four
which was not good but yeah after after
i saw the news i
was kind of relieved and happy for the
team because as i said before i felt
that we
played really well uh during the whole
season and we
deserved uh really deserved to win the
tournament so
yeah i was happy and relieved i
i don't know them really well i mean i
know
the players of course but i i wasn't
really
following their trajectory over the
whole
pro league but yeah i mean
as i said before it's this is a problem
with online chess that you know
there's this possibility there
and it's just sad when when when
there is a proof that the
the the fair play policies have been
violated and
it's just bad for for chess in general
so
um i did feel a bit sad about that
uh i feel that we have to do
whatever is necessary to try to minimize
that
somehow i feel that it's really hard to
to
be 100 or close to 100 sure
but definitely you would need
like something more
i think than than what we had
at the process league finals
like in terms of cameras like maybe more
than one
just like minimum i think two or three
and
and of course ideally you would you
would like to have some
some kind of uh person there to make
sure but i know it can be difficult to
arrange but
but yeah at least at least i think uh
two or three cameras would be would be
better
and just essentially all that
we can do to try to minimize the risk
and
try to make sure that players are
not really worried about these kind of
things would be would be nice
other than that i think the system was
good and it was
spectacular enough and and
if if if they can
keep it like that for next year that's
that's fine
um yeah i think definitely he he had a
point i mean he's a
very strong player and very experienced
player also in in terms of online chess
so i think he is quite sensible in in
what he was saying
and yeah after
i also did some analysis of the games
and i
kind of had similar feelings
congratulate everyone on
[Music]
our victory and i just hope that
we can continue to win more titles
interesting takes by lenny dominguez
right there and as you might know
lenny dominguez not only contributed
between the matches in against
the india yogis but also in the crucial
chinese pandas match as you may know
the chinese pandas did take
third place after they defeated
the chess bras so without any further
ado
let's take a look at the dominguez's
game versus
lee chao which was very important
between the archbishops and
the chinese pandas e4
c5 knight f3 a6
a typical move
the o'kelly trying to avoid any kind of
preparation and that kind of shows
how much they respect
lenny is opening knowledge trying to
avoid
the main lines the mainline night orbs
and try to get
more and much range closer to the middle
game instead
now dominguez unsurprisingly chose
the aggressive c4 move trying to get
into a marotzi type of structure
just a side note you can also go c3 and
d4 trying to build a
c3 cc on light position where a6
is not the best move c4
knight c6 d4 take 6
e5 and one of the nature
of super grand masters if they see a
subpar variation or they face one
they will always look for the strongest
response
they will not shy away from punishing
their opponents
now white could go knight c2 knight f3
knight b3 all very reasonable moves
however they are not ambitious dominguez
immediately goes knight f5 stating
that in this case unlike in
the kalashnikov black would have d5 move
but in this position there's actually
two pawns
blocking that so if d5 is played white
is not
forced to capture with the e pawn in
fact d5
was played by lee chao c takes d5
takes takes knight d4
now someone with less experience might
panic here
and say oh lee chao might have prepared
an
idea in this position however after
carefully observing you can notice that
even though
white is behind in development lenny
does have the bishop pair
so if he manages to survive
the opening phase he will have a very
promising position
so he continues on resolutely with
knight c3 knight f6
and bishop g5 and bishop g5 is
a very crucial move in this position
because you got to stop black's
initiative
before it's too late bishop g5
pinning and also stopping any threats
of knight takes d5 which p7
takes sort of slowing down
black's play ship takes f6 bishop d3
g6 castles and castling is actually a
very very smart choice by dominguez
as he notes that in the long run he has
to be better
has an important pawn on d5
the pieces are val coordinated while
this king on e8
is a little bit suspicious g takes f5
knight e2
immediately aiming for an opposite
colored
metal game one thing that you need to
learn
and i'm pretty sure that dominguez
already knows
decide who's attacking in an opposite
color middle game
is the one going and calling the shots
and it's clearly white as black has just
too
many pawn islands and a weakened king
i take c2 queen takes c2 queen d7
seemingly everything's fine
black is in control but
here lenny spots an idea and plays
queen f3 seemingly blundering e4
however e4 runs into bishop takes c4
and it turns out at the end of the day
you are going to
lose that bishop and with this weakened
king
on e8 you just have a terrible position
as black so lee cho was forced to play
f4
rook c1 no long castling
allowed ship g7
rook d1 simple but strong
just getting all his rooks on the open
files
queen d6 queen g4 but
look at how strong these moves are
they're all full of purpose the
c1 rook controls the c8 square so
there's no long castling
the rook on d1 supports this passer on
d5
and queen g4 is setting up four mating
attacks
in the future bishop f6 and this is
again an important turning point
of the game i'm very certain
that lenny is spotted this tactical
trick of bishop takes h7
and it works because rook 87 would lose
either the h7 rook or the a81
however it is a team competition
so you do not want to risk if you do not
need to
and here as a great team player as
dominguez is
said i do not need to get into those
maybe the h file would actually be
useful for you as black
so i am just going to double up on the c
file
rook d8 bishop e4 consolidating
f8 rook c1 and once this rook
enters it'll be clear that the advantage
that dominguez has
is near decisive g8
queen h3 rook c7
queen b4 you can see that the chao
is desperately trying to unsettle lenie
but it's impossible queen f5
rook g6 and probably the
second most impressive move by lenier
he plays g3 making sure there are no
back rank issues
and creating a bit of a luft for this
king on g1
and now the game is practically decided
queen b6 king g2 no more tactical
trickies
king g7 queen e6 simple but strong
quite like the whole game attacking the
queen on b6
and threatening the f7 pawn with
decisive
threats the game continued with queen
takes e6
d takes bishop g5 check king g8
and sometimes clarity is the one thing
that matters
so even though rook c7 might just win
the game
there's nothing as clear as just taking
the rook the ship takes c1
bishop 87 king h8 and e7 which
actually won the game as rook f8 is
unstoppable
and dominguez is going to promote
so that brings us to the second
interview
with var okobian as there are plenty of
players
who hadn't played in the finals
namely alejandro ramirez la quang liam
and var ocobian and their couple
of others as well but they also had
strong opinions
about the matches let's listen in
oh harsh pictures did fantastic in my
opinion and
as lania mentioned earlier a besley saw
was just like
phenomenal throughout the whole season
fabi played really well geoffrey played
really really well la quan liang played
really well
uh lanier everybody was playing well i
did commentary for our i think
uh quarterfinals and all those matches
and we were super excited to qualify to
the finals and go to norway actually
to win the title in norway in person in
front of
live crowd and we were making plans and
everything
how we gonna go there do the stream and
do some commentary live from there but
unfortunately all that
as you know didn't happen because of the
covet dinner and
then eventually it was postponed for
many many months the finals and it
happened online
yeah i just really wish it was the other
way around we could have
played the final in life everybody
pretty much that we're
we are the team we are the team to beat
i mean chess brothers really
strengthened their team this year
they brought in on ishkiri they brought
in greece they had a strong lineup as
well
of course chinese china pandas are very
dangerous as well
but still i don't think they could keep
up with our top players
well to be honest with you i didn't know
anything about it until i got the email
friday i think that was the announcement
was made right
thursday yeah so the day announcement
was made and i got an email from my
camera i opened the email that
he said this is what happened that
[Music]
we are the champions because armenian
eagles are disqualified so i clicked on
a link and i read
the details of the press release from
chess.com
and uh for for a moment i you know
i was like pretty shocked i didn't know
what to think you know because you know
i play for saint louis team for many
many years
but i also know the players on the
armenian team so it was
uh mixed feelings i mean the situation
in armenia as you probably you guys know
most of people who are watching the news
there's been a war in armenia
since september 27th so when the finals
were played that was the second day of
the war
because thereby jump it's still going on
right now every day people dying on both
sides it's like a very serious war it's
not just
a little bit of shooting here and there
no it's just like battleground if you
see the videos you'll be like
really shocked to see what's happening
so it's like a real war
uh and that was the second day so so
definitely the armenian players
there were two armenian players who were
playing the match uh petrossian and
martirosian the other two players
from iran and from india there are two
players for the final match
so yeah definitely they were probably
under some stress
because you know i probably have family
members in a war so
definitely was you know very very
difficult day
for the armenian team i was very
surprised because
uh very very surprised to find out
and yeah pretty shocking
when i read everything and
we have trained together we've played
many tournaments together
so i've known him since
childhood we played i'm a little bit
older than him so we played
very very strong player very talented
player
i've been uh
very very very accomplished player too
twice olympic champion
winner of most of the big tournaments in
us i think it was 2018 he came here and
won national open world open
so he's a fantastically strong player
so that's why it's very hard for me to
take sides you know so i'm just gonna
wait to see what's
you know gonna follow up you know
because we know tigran says you know he
denied everything so he's gonna try to
prove so we'll just have to wait to see
what will happen you know i think it's
not good for the image
because it's uh it's at a very high
level
very high level from that point of view
but i think from another point
maybe it will you know help in to get
some more
features some other methods to use at
the such a final event you know where
so much at the stakes you know add some
more measures
to make sure it's you know fair play so
everybody know that
this is just this is the very fair play
there's no no questions for anybody
i want to just congratulate our team
including archbishop for winning
the championship two years in a row and
three out of four years three out of
four years a big congratulations to the
team manager
my comer to the players to tony rich all
the people who make this possible so i'm
very proud to be part of the team
so very happy and looking forward to be
a part of team next year
interesting takes by var okobian
and as avora mentioned they were
people who played amazingly throughout
this event jeffrey zhang as it mentioned
he had a very up and down a game
versus vaeyi and the mvp that is
vastly so now wesley so
has been one of the strongest
and most outperforming player of this
whole season so let's take a look at
his accomplishment versus availi
so in this game
they yi is playing white versus
wesley so bestly
actually plays the aggressive e5 move
e5 bishop b2 knight c6 e3
and as you might have noticed the whole
chinese team
was trying to dodge all the opening
preparation
that the saint louis archbishop team had
and it is very interesting to see how
much they respected
their opening knowledge knight f6
bishop b5 and i'm mostly astounded
by wesley's choice of not playing
the by now very usual bishop d6 move
now at first glance this seems to
ruin and decline all
the basic principles of chess
the bishop is stuck in there but on the
other hand it defends the e5 pawn
and after a6 this bishop will have to
move
with a long theoretical discussion
however
instead leslie clicked queen e7
which is a new idea and a breath of
new fresh air in this position finally
something exciting and not the same old
same old with bishop d6
excuse me knight c3 a6
so actually queen e7 has exactly the
same idea
but keeping the d-pawn push at reserve
trying to get that c8 bishop out and
that's actually
wesley's forte he loves playing
classical chess meaning
chess where you do not break the chess
principles
bishop c4 g6 and if you look at this
position
you can quite much tell that this bishop
ain't doing a whole lot
on b2 it's actually kind of struggling
there
and does not have enough pressure
on e5 and if that fails black's
position is just sound
therefore they embarks on
the sharpest possible move and plays h4
he is trying to create some tactical
havoc
before wesley could consolidate
now as you might expect wesley
doesn't want to have any part of that
game
so he refrains from bishop g7 now bishop
g7
would involve in exchange sacrifice
after h5 knight h5 knight d5
now things would start working for vayi
with threats on c7 and on the queen on
e7
and boom on h5 queen takes h5
and at least white has some play
against the weakened king on e8
however vastly as we talked about it
already
is a very solid player probably the most
reliable
team player we've seen so far it goes h5
just issuing any kind of complications
saying i don't believe you have anything
else
on the king's side so i might as well
just stop it
right now at f3 bishop g7
knight g5 on the other hand he did
give vae a nice little outpost on g5
castle castle d6 and finally
that said that bishop on c8 is freed
f4 and now
bishop g4 is played
oftentimes we'd underestimate
how these simple ideas work
now as we look at this position
it might have seemed a little bit
strange but queen e7
was a very very good start of a logical
idea
trying to remove all black's pieces onto
the
king side therefore fianchettoing
castling and then go
play d6 bishop g4 and as so far we can
see
white isn't doing that shabby because
that bishop on b2
is sort of walled up that knight isn't
where it's supposed to be and if anyone
has an advantage it must be black
as black has the central control
queen e1 sovay actually does the only
thing that you can do
if you have lost the central control
play on the flanks
and try to undermine your opponent's
king
now f4 is actually also threatening
ideas such as ftx e5
activating the rook and putting some
pressure
on f7 and there is actually a
very rare but not well known idea
if you can build this famous number four
in the king's gambit usually your attack
is working and it is very strong
now that would be true if the f file was
open
but it's vastly to move and he says
goes ahead and plays the e4 so that does
not work queen g3
still sort of preparing breaks with f5
but wesley knows if your opponent is
trying to strike
on the flank you've got to stop them in
the center
so it goes like b4
a bit threatening on c2 but that's not
the main idea
firstly tries to play d5 and
chase away this bishop once this bishop
is gone
black will just have a reversed french
which
is a treat who wouldn't want to play
against the french
a3 is a3 problem
not a problem says so
d5 if you take i'll take on c4
and black has the bishop pair and with
lots of pressure on d2
black is doing quite well so here they
opted for bishop e2 are we going
backwards
no says wesley we're playing d4 we're
trying to close off
our opponent's play even if he takes d5
there will be threats on c2
so instead they opt for bishop g4
dc bishop c3 knight d5
now the situation has cleared
but it didn't get any better for bay yi
even if you go bishop e2 now you
are likely to face some uncomfortable
threats
along this long diagonal and if you
don't have
exact counter play something decisive
to get the initiative you are more than
likely
to be worse here with white
so where he decides it's time to gamble
at all
but it's difficult to gamble versus
wesley
because wesley is a very staunch
defender
ship f6 bishop takes h5
and going
the way of the yaster school vastly
takes
everything okay one queen f6 rook f1
give me that bishop now knight e4
is just a ghost threat yes it's a check
and it detects the queen
but there's queen g6 and you're just
down a whole rook
so there he goes f5 queen d6
rook f4 and mesti again says i
don't believe in no ghosts knight e4
king h8 and here they realize that it's
time to resign and he did
because if he would have taken on d6
there's 90 to check
and that'll be too many rooks versus
not even a knight because after king f2
takes takes c takes d6
and veggie would have to face
two rooks versus no rooks
not a good deal versus a grand master
so this was one of those fabulous games
by wesley against a very very strong
and good tactician
as his chinese opponent is now
mvl isn't here and i don't know why i'm
mentioning mvl
i really wanted to say fabiano karana
even though wesley's been on
the roll and been doing splendidly this
whole season
on the first board we had fabiano
caruana
so we really need to take a look at one
of his games
incidentally he again faced off with
vaiy but i do want to show you this game
even though there were ups and downs
fabiano showed that even if you have a
bad position
or a somewhat of a difficult position
you can always look for counter chances
so let's take a look at that game shall
we
this is karana they yi
all right so e4 e6
the french the terrible terrible french
defense
d4 d5 e5 now there is nothing wrong with
the french defense
but there is and that's mostly the
bishop on c8
so that's the reason why everybody
and their grandmother plays the carl
khan because
that's the way to go you want a healthy
bishop
c5 c3 so corona chose this
e5 system just to keep this bishop
smothered on
c8 queen b6 knight f3
knight c6 the only downfall
as you will see in the system is that
white will have to
defend all of these three pawns to
consolidate
a3 ship d7 b4
fabi is trying to
get a bit more space on this side of the
board
rook c8 should be two knight e7
bishop b2 over defending
the critical square the d4 pawn
knight f5 castle bishop b7
queen d3 knight a5
nice little trick b a doesn't work
because
of queen takes b2 but corona
does not care he goes knight d2
just making sure there are no knight c4
ideas let's c4
take stakes queen c3 castles
now you might tell me that this is
decent for black and you're correct
because
compared to a usual french this bishop
actually has some breathing room now our
french
improves if you get some breathing room
for your bishop
if you don't then you're more
than big of a trouble we can tell
that in this position veyi is doing
fine if not slightly better already
knight d2 queen d8 bishop f3
bishop c6 takes takes now
you could never really take on c4
because there's this idea of b5
and you would be crying as you lose the
piece
so b5 is played so
once your opponent gets a c4 pawn
it makes sense to cut off the
ammunition with b5 so there is no a6 b5
life support for the c4 pawn rook c7
queen d5 rook d1 rook d8 and to be
honest with you
probably this is the happier kind of
french
french without the c8 bishop
knight f3 h5 bishop c1
trying to activate the bishop and that's
one of
those things that super grand masters do
and especially fabi
he makes sure he can get better piece
placement so he realized that this
bishop on b2 wasn't doing too much
so he's going to reroute that bishop via
c1
to e3 a6
rook b1 queen e3 bishop e3
8xb5 and again this is a critical moment
probably the first important moment of
the game
corona has been a little bit worse but
here he takes his chances
if white would take with the pawn
i would have no counter play probably
would have to just look around and see
what to do and just react to black's
play
however he takes on b5 at the rook
saying hey you've got a weakness
yourself
and this is the moment the game will
start turning
as corona will start pressurizing the b7
pawn rook a8 a5
rook d8 sadly for vayi he's at a loss at
the moment
what to do h3
again not doing much but
slightly slightly improving the position
a5
fixed this pawn on b7 h3 created a bit
of a lift for the king
so with every move fabi is improving his
position
while vege is visibly
sort of floating and not finding the
right plans
i take c3 f takes e3 h4
rook b1 now these pawns on e3 and e5
might look ugly it's a double pawn
however this e pawn
is supporting the d4 pawn which
kind of solidifies fabiano's position
rook dd7 and that's again a sign
that black no longer has an advantage
knight d2 queen g6 knight f3
now people often frown at others
repeating moves but sometimes it's a
nice statement saying
hey i don't think you're better i don't
know what you want
but i can repeat if i'd like to
sovayi i think with the next move goes
overboard and tries to win a position
where probably equality should be
preferred
something like queen e4 accepting
repetition
but they yi is an ambitious player
there's no fault in that
however queen g3 seems to be going in
the wrong
direction rook c1 just eyeing the c
pawn ship g5 in d2
should be six rook b4 g5
now g5 is asking for it
now don't show this necessarily to your
coach
they'll not like g5 either it's a move
you never want to see maybe it'll return
in your nightmares
but it also doesn't really make sense to
be completely honest with you
yes black is trying to play g4 but it
definitely locks up this bishop on h6
and i don't think it is positionally
correct
but it also turns out that knight h2
by karana is just super strong
not only threatening knight g4
but also pinpointing that there are some
problems on f6
and h6 probably vagi was kind of
counting on
winning the pawn on e5 but it really
doesn't matter
because after these pawn trades
white will have infinitely better pieces
f5 rook c8 check queen c2
not falling for cheapos such as knight
e5
queen e5 and then losing a piece
so queen c2
pinning the f5 pawn right king h1
g6 knight e5 hook c7 and
suddenly the b7 pawn
is the weakness and not the d-pawn and
that means
that white is in full control in this
position
ship g7 queen c5 and sadly for vayi
he has to part with the b-pawn
or has to trade on c7 he decided to take
take
and g4 was a very nice move trying to
muddy waters
even though he must be worse here
now here caruana chooses to take on g4
however i would have preferred taking on
b7
because knights actually enjoy closed
positions
so it kind of makes sense to keep it
closed as
much as possible however hdx g4 is
still a okay fg knight g4
there's still not many threats over
there the queen is protecting all of
those squares
queen f5 back to e5 h3
queen takes b7 and again this is
typical high class chess you
are not scared of anything you calculate
it
you just give a check then i go king h2
if you take on g2
well be it i'll capture it back and
there's nothing
going on h takes g2 in g2
bishop e5 d e check
king h2 b4 a6
and sadly you can't even check
and play for perpetual because this king
is
awfully placed if it was on a7 you could
hope
for a perpetual but in this case with
these kings
opposite each other this has
no hope queen ace a4 check
a7 queen c2 queen
g2 and resignation was
due because you couldn't even lurk
around
the king because there's queen h3
check and if you move anywhere else
there's
an a8 queen emerging and that's
game over and that is the last game that
i wanted
to show you guys and just as
you've seen a8 new queen
and the saint louis archbishops are the
champions
of 2020 thank you for watching
[Music]
you